welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down some brand new info
on Spider-Man 4 we'll also be talking
about some older leaks and how things
are going to play into Secret Wars which
could end towards the direction the MCU
is going obviously this stuff's all
still in early development but these
could provide the general outline for
where things are going to go you enjoy
the video then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every week without
the way huge thank thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
Spider-Man breakdown okay so no way home
ended with a big teaser that had Tom
hot's Venom being in the MCU though he
was sent home he left a trace of Venom
behind which means that the symbiot now
out in this universe Al though this
might seem like it's going to be a major
part of the next film from what I've
heard they're keeping venom out for a
while though this will be tied in it
won't be in a major way with them
setting up the black suit to then appear
in secret Wars this of course is what
happened in the comics with the 80s
event being where Peter first got it at
at the time they hadn't created Venom
yet and it was more just seen as a suit
that carried special abilities from what
I've been told that's the way it'll be
initially played with us getting minor
hints of something being off but nothing
too conclusive in the past in things
like the turby Maguire movies it's been
introduced and then became Venom
straight away here though from what I've
been told the Venom arcs being saved up
until Secret Wars with this new start it
will sort of go through a suit Trilogy
almost but it'll be spread across
Spider-Man 4 Secret Wars and then the
movie that follows it now I don't know
how stuff's going to get brought into
Spider-Man 4 and honestly I feel like
the suit might just be in a post-credit
scene maybe they do something where they
have the villains beating Peter and then
he gets the black suit and finally takes
them out at this point though Peter's
without all his stock Tech and the
upcoming film will have him being very
barebones the a that used to be in the
suits now gone and though down the line
of Venom voice could replace it they
want to keep things low key now that's
someone includes civilians too and my
source is back to a claim by my time to
shine they've said that Michael Mando
will be in the film as well with this
finally get enclosure on that homecoming
teaser on top of this Daniel rpk said
Michael Keaton's in the film and that
Marvel Studios is ignoring the morus
post credit scene also every time I say
mobus I have to double check it right
because I've been saying Mobius for for
the past seven weeks and it's just a
stupid name now nevertheless though it
it's quite a wild thing to have happen
and I imagine that Keaton and Mando will
interact at some point Sorry if you're a
big uh mobus fan there as well it's not
a stupid name I don't don't know why I
said that I quite like the guy but
either way when we last saw Michael
Keaton and Michael Mando both were in
prison so I think this will be how the
characters are both used potentially
Keaton might even know Peter Parker
exists and this is because he was off in
the morus timeline who knows maybe man
gets pulled back and then he can explain
how he manag to get jari Tech in an
alternate universe now on top of this we
also had Josh from den of nerds earlier
in the air talking about how he had Toby
Maguire was going to play a part in the
film this has since been backed up by a
number of different scoopers over the
weekend with Daniel rpk saying this film
will be something that merges Sony's
spiderverse with Tom Holland's version
so potentially that's how they get
Michael Keaton into it and morbius
brings an intriguing element into it as
well this could set up things with Venom
and hey I might be wrong with the black
suit not being in it it's just what I
heard mate now Venom 3 will drop in 2024
and that could tie into it and also
allow The Other Side characters to be
brought across from other projects like
Madame web and other stuff at the moment
because of the spell Peter's on his own
so it makes sense to have new characters
come from other places instead of
leaning on him being by himself for the
entire film now another thing in the
Multiverse is how it all plays into Loki
but the timeline for that show kind of
explains it the events of season 2
actually happen before no way home with
only the scenes after Loki ascends then
happening after so basically Loki sat on
the throne and then helped hold the
Multiverse together and this is how the
events of no way home them played out
that somewhat ruptured everything but
the Multiverse also will apparently be
absent from the main plot of the film
still though they're going to have to TI
to Secret Wars so I kind of Imagine
there'll be some way that this is
brought into the end the next Spider-Man
film will release before the next
Avengers and it's important to have at
least some things set up on top of this
there's been several rumors coming from
other sources in the scoop game that
have all talked about how Peter Parker
is the chosen one I did try and search
who posts to this rumor first but
unfortunately I couldn't find who broke
the initial news if you know though then
please drop a below and I'll see it put
up as the pin comment either way this
makes a lot of sense and it's something
that's also been happening in the comics
now in case you don't know Kevin far is
currently overseeing Marvel Comics 2 and
there's theories he's setting things up
for the future of the MCU this is why so
many of us think Loki's Avengers Prime
because it's something that also
happened in the comics now Peter being
the chosen one appears in that as well
with him being referred to it in end of
the spiderverse in the end it was was
revealed to be actually Cindy Moon who
you might also know as being silk still
though she's not been introduced in the
MCU and they might bring her in but I've
not heard any Rumblings yet now what it
basically means though is that the 616
Peter is sort of the Prototype Peter
that all of the other ones spun out from
however he also has a greater role in
the greater Cosmic universe and that's
sort of why no way home went the way it
did that sort of takes us in secret Wars
which is also what his role will be
there too Peter will be seen as the in
one of that with the rest of the cast
being made up of many faces from across
a number of different franchises all the
breadcrumbs are laying with the X-Men
will pay off there massively too with us
also getting the older Spider-Man actors
returning as well contracts are
obviously still getting worked out but
we reported this last year as well as
the idea that this is going to provide a
soft reboot for things going forward
again this has since been backed up by a
number of different sources and from
what I've been told that's what's
currently going on behind the scenes
Marvel have realized they have way too
many characters already and the
introduction of the X-Men's going to add
way way more to that so what Fig's
planning on doing is scaling things back
and once more having a more centralized
Universe I think looking back at the
early faces especially they work because
there wasn't much going on he had Iron
Man and then he popped up in the
Incredible Hulk with Iron Man 2 then
setting up Thor Thor then set up the Tes
before we hit Captain America and that
of course then led into the Avengers now
though you've got about two most credit
scenes the movie all setting up
different things years down the line
Shang Chi's got two that could really go
anywhere and then you got Harry Styles
in eternals and stuff like Guardians 3
as well you've also got clearin doctor
strange and none of this seems to really
be that linked So the plan is to kind of
scale things all back and have more
centralized stories for the main
Universe on the offshoot stuff we'll get
more experimental things which is mainly
what Marvel spotlights been invented for
I still don't know how Sony's going to
play with this either but there's also
plans to make a liveaction Miles Morales
film I think he'll probably be brought
across soon and might even come in the
main Universe at some point in the
future still though we're very early
days and we're going to see how things
will shake out I know though that the
Marvel's box office will have them
scared as well as the declining
viewership in the Disney Plus shows Loki
had some big numbers in the end but
secret Invasion fell off and it kind of
shows the whole state of Interest So the
plan is to scale things back and look at
what works and what doesn't and I
imagine that will be getting less Disney
plus stuff too so far it seems like
they're re shhoting a lot of things with
Daredevil being one that's going from
the ground up Captain America is also
getting re- shoots too which are
currently going to go over 4 months he
could probably film an entire movie in
their time and it kind of shows the
amount of work that they have on their
hands anyway in conclusion the main PL
to have Spider-Man 4 Once More tackling
the Multiverse and it'll sort of be a
rebuilding of the character with his
origin story happening in those first
three home films kind of feel like the
spell will get reversed too and that
he'll go to strange and tell them all
about it might actually go to Ned with
him being a wizard but it will finally
bring the world back up to speed as it
falls apart in the initial stages of
Secret Wars still though there's lots of
things to look forward to and let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
you want to get some heavy spoilers
Mitch we've also got our t-shirt line
located below the video that will let
you pick up all kinds of tops like our
Theory time one house of dragon stuff ly
and a lot more we drop new designs on
there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out and huge thank you if
you bought one now if you want some else
to watch we've got a video on screen
right now so definitely head over there
right after this but out the way huge
thank you for sticking through the video
I've been your host Paul and I'll see
you next time take care peace